just two weeks ago shannen doherty
stunned the world by posting a series of
photos shaving her head after an
aggressive round of chemotherapy yeah
Kevin ow Shannon's talking only to
Entertainment Tonight about why she
decided to share these very personal
photos her diagnosis and also her brave
battle to survive
yeah the 902 1o star opened up to our
senior news editor Jennifer perils
revealing the terrifying truth that her
breast cancer has spread
I had a single mastectomy in May where
my tumor was and the fact that it wasn't
just one tumor it was a couple of
different tumors which is why I had to
have a mastectomy I couldn't have like a
lumpectomy living without a breast is
manageable it's it's the worry of your
future and how your future is gonna
affect the people that you love Shannon
only had one breast removed at her
doctor's recommendation and she does not
carry the breast cancer gene but she did
learn that the cancer in the breast she
removed had spread from one of my
surgeries we discovered that some of the
cancer cells might have actually gone
out of the lymph nodes so for that
reason we are doing chemo and then after
chemo I'll do radiation did they put a
stage number on this they they do a
stage when they take the tumor out
you know once it starts spreading you're
you're above stage 2 you're stage 3
stage 8 before whatever it is but I my
treatments are my treatments there's
nothing I can do to change it like stage
3 stage 4 stage it's not gonna change
that you're still going through chemo
I'm still going through whatever my
doctor is telling me to go through
because I trust them it was 16 months
ago that Shannon was first diagnosed now
she doesn't want to know what stage
she's in and how far the disease spread
is not important to her she just wants
to focus on the fight itself has it
spread to anywhere else in her body I
mean we don't really as of now no but
you know we don't we don't know because
it did when we took out some of the
lymph nodes we did notice that when the
lymph nodes was patru one of the cancer
cells was protruding out of the
she first knew something was wrong when
she felt something on her breast you
were in the shower doing a self breast
exam yes was that the first time you
knew something was wrong yeah I mean I
don't know if it was that I knew
something was wrong but I felt something
felt something went to the doctor I did
not go to the doctor right away
I my I can't I can't get too into this
because I'm in the middle of a lawsuit
at the moment so I'm not allowed to talk
about it and so I didn't have insurance
to cover me for going to the doctor
after completing chemo and radiation
Shannon will have reconstructive surgery
Sharon Osbourne Christina Applegate and
Angelina Jolie all opted for
reconstruction after their mastectomy x'
dr. J or anger who reconstructed
Angelina's breasts is working with
Shannon and during an early surgery he
left her with a little surprise he
didn't want me to wake up with
absolutely nothing it was very important
to him that that I didn't have that
experience and so he put an expander in
and so you know I have a tiny something
there it's cute and sometimes we fill it
up and make it bigger it's so nice being
so personal right now but I think a lot
of women can probably go yeah I've been
through that and it's great though you
get to pick out what's nice you pull up
the shopping everyone anger exactly